Speaker 1: Sean HANNITY on his radio show
was confronted by a caller saying, Dude,
you lied on air. You knew Trump didn't really
win in 2020. We know from the text messages that
were revealed and we know from Rupert Murdoch's
deposition under oath, we know you were lying when
you went on air and said, oh, there was fraud and
Trump really won and all of this different stuff.
And HANNITY tries to backpedal and explain away.
And it is a delight to see. This is from the Ari
MELBER MSNBC show where they compiled a bunch
of different things. The back story, of course,
is that on air on Fox after the 2020 election,
HANNITY And Laura Ingraham and Tucker and many
others were pretending. We now know that they
agreed, yeah, Trump really won. It was stolen. Joe
Biden didn't really win. And privately, they were
texting each other saying, these people are crazy.
This doesn't make any sense. Take a look at this.
Speaker 5: You knew the election wasn't stolen
from Trump and you guys lied
about it anyway because you
felt you had a good reason.
Speaker 1: So this is a caller
to Hannity's show a few days ago.
Speaker 6: No, if you listen to what
I said on the air every day, what did
I talk about? Well, let me remind you,
many Americans do not believe that this
election was fair. I feel that way. Why do you
say corrupt and an embarrassing disgrace while.
Speaker 5: Asking you if you all knew that the
election wasn't stolen from Trump and yet you.
Speaker 6: No, no, no. You're not listening to
what I'm saying. I said I had problems,
that there were integrity issues. Our
Dominion system is prone to human error.
72 million Americans voted for Donald
Trump. All of them, all of us deserve an answer.
Speaker 1: Right? So this is just a sampling of
the placating that HANNITY did. So, listen, it's
at this point, there really isn't a question. We
know that people like HANNITY and Ingram and
Tucker Carlson are entertainers and they are
propagandists. And at the time, the way the wind
was blowing, they couldn't come out and say, guys,
Trump lost. That's it. That's what they knew.
That's what they believed. That's what they
said privately. Trump lost. Joe Biden won. But
they're not in a position to actually say that to
their audience because there were 63 lawsuits and
they were their producers were booking guests for
them like Sidney Powell and Rudy Giuliani and the
entire thing. So they did what they had to do as
entertainers while privately there had they had
their views about the facts of the matter. This
proves to us they aren't true believers
when it comes to someone like Sidney Powell,
that kooky lawyer who has been disbarred
now from multiple bar associations.
She does seem like a true believer. She actually
seems insane. She raises religious aspects to what
she did and believes. And all these are she seems
genuinely out of her mind like a true believer.
But HANNITY, Tucker Ingram and others, they didn't
believe it. We suspected they didn't believe it.
They wanted to maintain their audience. Says they
wanted to maintain their jobs and their incomes,
and probably in many of these cases, they wanted
to maintain friendliness with Donald Trump
himself. Good for this caller for confronting
HANNITY. We will see what the repercussions
are. But I'm increasingly reading legal analyzes
that suggest Fox News could really, really, really
be in trouble here. This is not, you know, yes,
Rupert Murdoch has the money to pay the defamation
lawsuit, but that this could significantly hurt
FOX News depending on what happens. And that
would be great. And it's not about me. You know,
I know that they're I'm already getting messages
from right wingers saying, David, you're just
advocating for censorship. When you say, I hope
this lawsuit is terrible for Fox News. You're
advocating for them to be censored. No, no, no.
We're talking here about consequences
to defamation, consequences to defamation.
We're talking about a legal system and a
legal structure here. I am a defender of Fox News
being allowed to say whatever they want to say,
but there are certain things they can say which
could have consequences if some of their speech
is defamatory. There is a legal process that
is part of our judicial system that would hold
them accountable. So what I am talking about,
what I am pushing for, is accountability. It is
not about revenge censorship or curtailing free
speech. Fox News did this thing. They have been
sued and it is now in the courts to figure out
what the repercussions should be. Maybe tomorrow,
maybe Wednesday, I will do a deeper dive into
how this might actually destroy Fox News.